- Your whole foundation of
what deep dish is is wrong.
- Deep dish has too much foundation.
That's my problem.
- I got a nice blond roast
because I am a blond roast.
When I say it to the barista
and it kills every time.
- He told me had to go to
trombone lessons at 7am,
on a Sunday.
- Yeah, you can't date
someone when they can't
come up with a better
instrument, ridiculous.
- You got down and dirty
and don't have to deal with
any of the detrimental damages.
I'd stop complaining.
- Okay, well, did you have
a better night than me,
Mr. Snapchat?
Okay, I saw your story.
- Just went to Alfie's birthday thing.
- Oh, I didn't think he
was doing that this year.
- Oh, yeah.
Didn't you get the Facebook invite?
- No, no, I don't think so.
- That's weird.
- Yeah, that is weird.
Well, I bet it was just like
every other year, right?
Ferber got too drunk, Leslie
hooked up with everyone.
- Yeah, kinda.
- Kinda?
- Yeah, well, you know,
he sold that startup
and so it was also kinda like
a big celebratory throw down.
- So it wasn't at his apartment?
- He rented the roof at that
new place downtown, The Roof.
- Like the whole roof?
- Well, not the whole thing.
A lot of it's inside.
He rented the parts that were outside.
- Wait, hold on.
Neil, you went?
- Yeah.
- I didn't even know you
and Alfie were friends.
- We met in line at the
In-N-Out a few weeks ago.
- In line at In-N-Out?
Me and Alfie went to college together.
- Okay, look, it wasn't
that great, alright.
It was just a classic Hollywood party.
You know, models falling into
pools, celebs everywhere.
You could ride a tiger.
You didn't even need a saddle.
That was cool, I liked that part of it.
But the rest of it was just kinda boring.
- First of all, that sounds amazing.
Second of all, you went, Zach?
- Yeah, Neil invited me.
- Oh, come on.
Wait, that's why you cut our picnic short?
- Yeah, I'm sorry about that.
- Wait, you guys go on picnics together?
- It's a sacred monthly tradition.
- Why am I not invited?
- I like the outdoors.
I'd go to a picnic.
- Yeah, that sounds a little shady.
- I love picnics.
- That's like something you guys are doing
without us.
- Let's all five of us go on a picnic.
(yelling at each other)
- Guys, guys, guys, guys.
It's okay for us to do things
without each other, you know?
Like, we don't all have to be
there in order to be friends.
I think that's my package from my grandma.
Just got her a Christmas present.
But guys, we're best friends.
Nothing's gonna change that.
- Yeah, got a special delivery for Zach.
- Georgina, you're a mailman.
- Wow, how are you even
conscious right now?
- Oh, I know.
Last night was so crazy.
- Crazy.
Are we still on for that picnic or?
- Are you freaking kidding me?
(upbeat techno music)